this is a production of Cornell
University
I pleased to introduce today's speaker
step on mentally learn before I go
through the formal introduction though I
wanted to introduce some work that he
did in my lab earlier on so Stefan
actually came to Cornell to work in the
tank Scilab where he stayed for a couple
of years and then he came to my life to
work on the project I'm about to
describe to explain what he did I have
to explain how I got tenure because this
slide explains what I did during my
assistant professorship because he came
to my lab right after that so we were
what we were interested in this question
of cytoplasmic meals early and gently
encoded fertility restoration this is
one of the reproductive isolation
methods of plants used at the time I was
assistant professor we didn't actually
know quite cytoplasmic genome was
encoding this trait of cytoplasmic male
sterility but it was chloroplasts and
mitochondria we didn't know what gene
was doing this and we also didn't know
anything about this nuclear included
fertility restoration gene that could
restore the pollen development to this
plan so what my lab did was look in
petunia to try to find the gene was
encoding cytoplasmic male sterility so
if you have a fertile line with the
recessive allele of the RFG it's 40 if
you have a recessive allele in with the
CMS cytoplasm it's sterile you see the
lack of Poland about
another one and then if you have one
copy of the fertility story you get a
normal fertile plan so what we found was
that there is a toxic protein encoded by
an abnormal gene in my condom and a day
and that sterile plan and the RF allele
prevent expression of this toxic protein
so that's what we knew and that's how I
got tenure was that finding but then
when when I came here and Stefan
enjoying the lab we wanted to find out
with the RF genius at that time we
didn't know what RF genes were so what
Stefan did was an amazing effort to try
to identify that RF teen and Petunia
which is our normal system at the time
there was no genome for petunia there
was no high-throughput sequencing there
are almost no genetic resources to step
on it and develop those all from scratch
including a a buyback library all the
markers and after a a an effort that
took three success of two-year USDA
grants he was able to figure out what
the RF gene encoded he found that it
coded in tow truck of peptide repeat
protein this was the founding member of
these this protein family for these
restores and it's now known that most
restore genes implants are PPR so-called
PBR protease you hearing more about them
in sedation because in organelles it's a
small world but it's it's now known
these puppies are now not to be a large
family of RNA binding proteins that
controller can help gene expression and
this protein turns off the expression of
that toxic gene and that toxic protein
so Stefan then moved from working on
this petunia RF projects to working on
RNA editing and that's what he's going
to describe today step on Goffe his
bachelor's degree in biochemistry at the
University of Science and Technology in
Montpelier plants and an MS degree and
agronomic science at the inn Romney
swollen too loose and then a PhD in
molecular genetics at University cloud
Bernard lyon in France as I eventually
came to Tanksley lab first in my lab and
he's recently been promoted to be a
research scientist in the department of
molecular biology and genetics thanks
for in for this very nice introduction
ok now I have my little to the shoe can
stop so I'm going to tell you today
about the unraveling the complexity of
plant RNA editing machinery and in the
first slide I just an overview of my
talk with a little background about what
plant RNA editing is and then are we
identify some of the components of this
plant elitism which is the molecular
machinery responsible for this
modification and we use the three
different approach genetics biochemistry
approach and then what I call a moto G
and I will illustrate what I mean by
that in during the talk and in the last
part of my talk i'll tell you about new
editing factors which have not been
published yet and the future direction I
want to take my research on so
it's blocked oh so because I'm not using
the right one ok so our editing is a
common type of RNA processing and it
occurs in many many species and under
very different mechanism so it happens
in various trypanosome squid plant which
is going to be the topic of my talk
today and even as human being in plant
the it's a post-transcriptional
modification some transcripts either sit
cited in being modified to you reading
and this is restricted to only the
organelle genome so here the arab adopts
this is the plan for them you working on
and so in the chloroplast about 40 seas
are modified to yuri Dean and in
mitochondria in the same phenomenon
except is much more frequent over 600
seas are modified to origin in the
mitochondrial genome and the reaction
that that is responsible for this is a
germination where the amino acid here is
in a city cited in is replaced by a keto
group and thus the saturnine is modified
to you reading so very often people are
wondering why plants edit and so in
implants in the plant world this is a
corrective mechanism that allows the
plant or the functional protein
because the the the amino acid after
editing is actually encode a more
concept amino acid and also you can
create start or stop codon and ear I
give you an example of plastic
transcript and the HD where the start
codon in the ACG so it's not a start
column but upon editing vc is modified
to urine in and thus start codon is
creating and that allows the of course
the protein to be translated so this is
an important mechanism for plants
development because no editing most
article on most article on no protein
and so the loss of editing really
results in many different and various
phenotype depending on where it occurs
so here in this example I this is an
editing newtons which is unable to edit
a specific see on the transcript that
encodes the plastid RNA polymerase and
as a result this mutant can see is very
sent and as is not autotroph and has to
be run on a sucrose medium but in our
favorite Newton's in the lab so this
this mutant plants is unable to dt the
specific see on a sec d plastic
transcript and you can see that there is
no obvious phenotype associated with is
defect in editing compared to the
wild-type and here I give another
example and this is a mitochondrial
mutant in editing so these little plant
is unable to lead to seize on transcript
that encode a small ribosomal protein
and as a result the translational defect
and so these branches are obviously a
slow growth phenotype and then when the
defect in editing occurs in very
important position in the essential gene
it's an embryo if of the plant is not
able to make it so i told you in the
introduction that not all the seeds are
edited to you read in the specificity
only for TCS IDT dinner in a plastic and
around 600 so definitely not all the
fees i heated and so this the
specificity is really dependent upon two
elements first there's this element
which is a small ribonucleotide sequence
which is a upstream of the seeds to be
edited and so in this video figure i
showed that theses don't add this
assignment so they won't be edited this
he possess this assignment and so you
will be modified to origin but that's
only a part of the equation the other
obviously is trans factor that's gonna
recognize this element binds to the CC
element and then process the sea and
modify it were you reading and so in
this complicated slide that was done
some time ago but by a postdoc in the
lab Charles the this side showed that
this trans factor that we call plant
editor is actually a small protein
complex so what Charles did he extracts
protein from chloroplast and then sighs
fractionated them on the size exclusion
chromatography and so this is all the
fraction from the the big one for the
small one and then he sa each fraction
for editing activity and so I don't want
to go into deterrent to the essay
just for you to understand is that these
bands the morning turns his band and the
more active for eating is the fraction
and so this van the number 13 is the is
the most is where the band is most
intense here is the just quantification
of this band and this band is again is a
comprised between 200 and 400 kilo
dalton thus demonstrating that its plant
elitism is a small protein complex and
so the game in the lad was trying to
find the components of this plant
elitism and because I'm a geneticist at
that time I was working on on CNS but I
also developed this as a side project
and these are a different ization of
arabidopsis shot from above and the the
point of this slide is just to show you
our diverse these plants are in the size
and morphology of there was that leaves
and so looking at this pan I thought
that maybe also they were differing in
the way they edit their seeds and
actually that was a good guess otherwise
I won't talk about it and so with the
previous that was years ago 10 over 10
years ago with a postdoc in the lab and
launched a teeny we study this
particular transcript ECB 206 which is
called also CC NB and we we were
interested we focus on this transcript
because it's the transcript that possess
the highest number of a DDT that's about
40 seas that are edited so in one
experiment we could potentially look for
difference between these two widely used
as asian runs very and columbia at 40
position along the transcript and here
is an electropherogram and you can see
that this position the columbia is more
edgy than the director
because the T peak is higher in Columbia
that it is in the in Landsberg director
and once once you have a difference in
parent I'll ization that's almost the
end of the story not really but in
arabidopsis because then you can use
many genetic resources other people have
crossed these two these two guy and so
you can use the progeny to study the
segregation of this differential extent
in the progeny and that's what we did
several times and a I just show you an
example so we found that one of the gene
controlling these differential editing
extent was actually in in this area
which is on chromosome 2 and with a wall
tonight was an undergrad doing silly
faces sorry with me what Walter did a
screen many many hundreds of progeny
coming from the cross between landsberg
and Columbia and these are this progeny
this plant and they are recombinant
because they have inherited part of the
genome from i'm going to try sell to
shake from lands bearing in blue and
part from columbia in red and and then
what Walter dds a the editing extent of
all these progeny is for coming in
plants and so again if they were edited
like Columbia River red like a red tie
blue and then it's a regression of the
phenotype on a genotype you just have to
look at matching colors and the matching
colors are just between these two
recombination point and there there was
only one gene that we call rm14 required
for efficiency of mitochondrial editing
so we were pretty convinced because
there was only one gene that was the the
gene and this gene again is a PPR as
maureen told you in the introduction the
restoration of fertility is also a PPR
PPR because went a tripeptide repeat
that's the only time i'm going to tell
it it's composed by a repeat which are
35 I mean
long and in addition this protein
content some extra motif at the
c-terminus and so in order to
demonstrate that these this gene was
really disappointing was an editing
factor we looked at the mutant DNA
insertional mutant and we found one and
then we compared the level of editing
instant in the homozygous newtons which
add this T DNA which disrupt the
expression of this gene and the almost
arias wild-type and yes there was a
significant difference in the level of
imaging stand for this particular side
thus demonstrating that rm1 was really
the editing factor recognizing this
mitochondrial site so that illustrate
the genetic approach which was pretty
cumbersome so here the so we're going to
build up the model as a puzzle so this
PPR protein and a lot have time to show
you the evidence but the other one that
are the recognition factor they
recognize the season event and bind to
it and they are found both in the crop
last and in the mitochondrial editors oh
but there are other other component
because I told you at the very beginning
but that we knew that the this elite
ozone is about 200 and 400 kilo dalton
and the size of the PPR is way below
that so we knew that there were other
components and so the way we decided to
chase this component and that's a work
that I did in collaboration with Wade
error who used to be a vc MV student in
in the lab so what way did he put a flag
on on one of the our favorite PPR
factor called rare one and then using
antibody against this rare one it was
able to immunoprecipitated the all
complex and then with the collaboration
with the Van Wyck club where we were
able to identify one of the components
of these complex as being required for
RNA editing factor interacting protein 1
and so because this reponn was member of
these complex obviously we wanted to
know whether it was also an editing
factor and so as usual we looked at gdna
mutant and we found two while which was
in in the in the central and as I told
you before obviously these protein this
gene is essential gene because we were
unable to recover homozygous mutant for
this new talent but luckily for us we
are also a cdna inserted in the promoter
and we were able to recover almost i
goes newtons and you can see that this
plant is very effective in its
development and then by using bulk
sequencing we were we analyze all the ad
term meaning all these the ADT's in the
chloroplast of the plastid and in the
mitochondria and what we found was that
this mutant was effective in about a
third of this plastinated inside meaning
that the level of editing in the mutant
for this site was much reduced compared
to the wild-type but more importantly
about three quarter of the site in the
mitochondria were
effective and about 100 was really the
the level of editing was not even the
detectable by Bach sequencing it was
gone and that was a very exciting result
because it was the first time that
member I mean a component of the plan
todito Sam was not a PPR protein rip one
is not a PPR protein so then we wanted
to know because the PPR I told you bind
recognize and bind the RNA so we were
wondering how the specificity work for a
point what its targets because it
doesn't affect all the all the Seas many
fees but not all of them and that was a
work that was done by tau tau son was a
produced plant bio grad student working
in lab and what style showed by using
East library that actually the
recognition of our free porn for its
target was mediated through its
interaction with a recognition factor
and so in order to make you understand
what I just said I have this little
animation we're here you can see that in
the power blast kyosho Darrell one
interact with rip one sorry rip interact
with the rare one it also interact with
another recognition factor called CR 28
I'm not responsible for his name and
then but then rip one doesn't interact
with here 21 and so when the new in the
mutant rip one is not there anymore or
is very reduced and then only the site
that for which reprod interacts with the
recognition factor are affected in the
mutant the sides for which rip one
doesn't interact with the recognition
factor does don't see there editing
little effective in the mutants and
what's true in the chloroplast is true
also in the plastid and tell showed also
that rip one was able to a modular eyes
by Easter hybrid okay so that's all this
story that the second part was to
illustrate the biochemist call approach
in order to identify components of the
plants elitism and and now I'm going to
tell you about the amala G and what I
meant by that is that rip one is a
member of a small tiny of protein in the
arabidopsis there are nine members this
is good so r upon which we found was a
involved in mitochondria and plus TD
editing and there's all these factors
and I identify them by using software
and this broke we call in the rib motif
it just amuro G block we don't know
really what the function obviously they
are important because they are conserved
in the rib family and then of course we
were wondering are any of these other
protein also editing factors and so and
this time instead of using bulk
sequencing I develop a method based on a
next-generation sequencing to analyze
Newton's or silence tissue from this
from this other gene and so briefly it's
very easy method where I use a specific
primer for all the organelle jeans so is
is the real RNA and some RNA are edited
more than other and then I do rt-pcr and
then
this thing are you know cdna whether you
eat transforming tea and then I share
the cna and use these shield fragments
to build up alumina library and then I
just align align these rates on the
genome and then I just count really then
the number of thread being t or blue
being c and the ratio of red rubies need
a very accurate measure of the level of
editing and that collaboration that I
did with the robot bukovski was a
bioinformatician here so I use these
methods to analyze the mutant and and
silence tissue in this other member and
i found that rib to and replying were
preceded in character while rid three
and repay or my token you're dissing
factor but also using these motifs to
integrate the database i found that
there was this weird protein that we
call on 14 organelle RNA recognition
motif containing protein 1 and it's a
weird one because it has a duplicated
REEP REEP domain which is also truncated
you can see there's some other blogs are
missing and in addition it has a motif
and c terminus which is called RN for
RNA recognition motif and so we were of
course interested to know whether this
on one also was an Indian factor and so
as usual we looked at the GDN
a mutant in the first exam and so you
can see that this plant is really
morphologically okay but when we
surveyed the editor we found that the
mitochondrial item was not affected but
the placidity term was effective in each
mutant and about two-third of the
editing site where they were reduced in
the newton with 12 side which had a
major loss of editing and again we were
interested so I told you I don't know if
you remember that this protein here as
22 part rip rip that's how we identified
it and the RM and we were curious to
know which which part is important for
the editing ability of this protein and
again that's a work that was done by a
towel so here I show the 12 side that
are severely reducing the editing
instant in a mutant so the bar the blue
bar is the level editing in a white hat
but very high and in the mutant very low
and so what's tau did was to present he
transformed protoplast for the mutant
first with the reprint and when he did
that nothing really happened and when we
did the same experiment with the RM it
was able to complement most of the site
at least partially and so that was the
and to our surprise actually because we
were expecting more than repaid to be
involved in anything because that's how
we identify this protein but actually to
our surprise it's the are and parts of
this protein that was responsible for
the editing
each of these protein so and then as for
rip 1 tau using East why breed studied
all these on one was recognizing is
target and it's the same story as 401
the the recognition is mediated through
its interaction with the with non
recognition factor which are PPR and so
again in the in the in the mutant when
on one goes down only the site for which
on one interacts with the PPR see there
editing extent to go down in the mutant
not this one because again on one
doesn't interact with real one and also
tell showed that on one was interacting
with other non
editing factor from the rib family reap
102 so now we are we just add other
parts in the puzzle the reap members the
aam one for the chloroplast and if I put
on one touching the RNA in this model
it's because by with collaboration with
the back lab I've shown that this on one
has some specificity for the RNA target
and this is a GF gel shift assay and you
can see this is one of the one of the
target of m1 and thus nice ships
compared to a non-target and this now we
have a new student at Andrew in the lab
was going to study more deeply these the
recognition and the binding of on one
for its RNA targets okay so this is for
the chloroplast what about the Mitel so
again the defining of these are M being
involved in editing open a new a new or
all area for us to explore because the
iron is very frequent motif in the
protein world and in a bit of ceaseless
about 200 protein that contain this RN
and so I'm sorry so we could have you
know use brute force and and test least
one with proteins that's much work and
so we're trying to be smart and what we
did was a video genetic analysis of the
based on the RM motif of all this
protein in arabidopsis so this RI motif
is about 18 amino acid and what we
observed was on one this new editing
factor was part of this specific played
continuing about 20 members and
obviously the question then was are
these also potential editing factors so
we got a grant with maureen that just
ended up for which more in what the main
pii was the copy i but lucky for us we
just got a new brand for which now I'm
the P I am wearing is the copy I and so
here now i'm going to show you the work
from Shaolin was a grad student in the
lab and just finished and so she study a
this clade of on protein and so that's
another way to represent all these
proteins so with the funding father is
on one so it has the reprint RM and all
the other protein which belong to
displayed and they do because the RM
found in his other arm are very similar
to the RN found in on one and so what
challenge shown during a PhD was that on
two three and four when mitochondrial
editing factor and the m6 is a plastid
in fact random chicks has not been
published yet and I'll talk about that
at the end of my talk and some of these
other member also possess extra domain
glycine rich domain so here are just
going to show you an example of
showering work again same story she out
to demonstrate that um three was a
mitochondria leading factor she looked
at the mutant and she got a mutant in
the Texan and then she compared the
level of editing in mitochondrial side
actually this this all three is involved
in the control of editing of twenty
percent of the mitochondrial side over
100 side but er just show only two so
here is the level of editing extent in a
white type in grain and in magenta in
the mutant and you can see this is a
very significant difference level of
editing sent between the white side in
the mutant and the same is true for this
other side then what cha indeed was to
complement the these mutants by putting
a functional functional on three under
the control of 35s promoter and you can
see that she was able to restore the
level of editing and increase it very
significantly when compared to the
mutant the leveraging was from around
forty percent for this site to about 85
to 90 percent in the transgenic plant
and then we were wondering I told you
that the four on one what was important
was the RM motif and another repeat and
i'm free as to motive as the RM and the
glycine reach motif or domain sorry and
and then we of course were wondering
whether it was the same story as four on
one whether it was the RM domain or the
glycine which domain that was important
for the editing ability of this protein
and so what shall indeed was to again so
here's a mutant for a specific site and
its low edited about fifteen percent
when she when china the all flanks on
three she's able to restore the editing
level two forty five percent and when
she used only the RM again
she's able to significantly increase
increase the level of editing extent
thus again demonstrating that what's
important for the editing ability of
this protein is the RM motifs okay and
then as usual she was interested to know
whether these these new editing factors
was part of the editors amande was
interacting with other non editing
factor and here I just show you an
example see she used by a c4 bimolecular
fluorescence complementation and so she
put half of your pure four on each part
of the protein that she wants to study
the interaction on three and in this
case rip one and if they interact then
he will bring the two part close enough
so that they are able to fluoresce and
so then she did that in eco sheeana and
this is a negative control so these are
in red of the auto pure sent from the
chloroplast from the chlorophyll and
here is a close-up you can see that this
nice sports fluorescence when she did
this experiment demonstrating that all
three and rip one can interact in planta
so now now what's true for for
chloroplast is true also for
mitochondria so you have PPR you are
bleep and you are also on okay and then
we steal an interrogation mark here as
you can see and so we now also worked on
again by towel he did like use the same
strategy as why did but he put a flag on
the on one and immunoprecipitated eat
and then again with the collaboration
with the transferrin week
and we determined by mass spectrometry
that one of these protein that was
pulled down with on one was 0 z 1 z 1
for organization or one because this
protein contains zinc finger motif and
because Ozzy one was immunoprecipitated
with on one again we were wondering
whether Ozzy one was a leading factor
and as usual we looked at the DNA
insertional mutant and this time unlike
on one these mutant is not very happy
that's the mutant here so it's an albino
it's small and it has to be one on
sucrose medium and when we looked at the
editor of this mutant what we found is
that the majority of the plastid editing
side were affected in this mutant and
because this Aussie one was identified
for its interaction with on one we were
wondering whether there was overlap in
the site under the control of these two
editing factor and yes actually the
majority of the site 21 are cedar
editing incense severely affected in
both m1 and the Aussie one mutant so
Ozzy one belongs to a small family of
protein there's four members and again
this is a little diagram of how they
look like with the homology block and
the only really non motif is as I told
before he's a sinking a motive in this
light blue turquoise Ozzy one possessed
two of the zinc finger motif oh sorry oh
g1 or g2 as 20 z three 3 & 0 0 4 and
then of course the obvious question to
ask because he worked for it works for
all of these other members also editing
factors
so now I hope I convince you that the
planted is awesome our complex protein
small but complex which contain several
protein so and that also they contain
the same protein in both the
mitochondria ID tourism and the progress
PPR which had the recognition factor
that bind to the target rip on an Aussie
Aussie has been just demonstrated in Pro
procedures are not yet in the
mitochondria okay so now in the last
part of my talk I'm going to tell you
about a new plastic editing factor on
six OOP yes anaam 6 actually as the from
the start we had a strong presumption
that this was also an easy teen factor
because the RM found in this protein is
the most similar to UM one so again what
we did was to study
editing mutant sorry mutant t-dna
international mutant and when we use SDS
pcr sec this next generation based
approach to study the editor of these
mutants we found that there was no
mitochondrial editing defect but there
was plastic editing effect so again here
in green is a level of editing extent in
the white type in magenta in were in
mutant for this particular protein on
six and you can see that this strong
reduction of anything in stand for this
side accd from one hundred percent goes
to thirty percent even more pronounced
for this I'd PSB f77 for which the
editing goes from one hundred percent to
five percent and just to show you that
it's not affecting this this other side
for which the same level of editing
instant in the white type and in the
mutant and it is another way to
represent the reduction it's the the the
the difference reported to the value of
the other white type so you can see that
the the side that explain the most
drastic reduction is this site on PS DF
so as we were as n decide this these
mutants are shorter growth phenotype and
also detecting the photosynthetic
efficiency and so as we were working on
this Newton's actually we found out that
another group was working on this mutant
yan liu and but she's a photosynthetic
person so she did not use the same
screen to to identify this Newton and
that's that's a word basically this wet
floors and it shows that the this mutant
is affected in this a photosynthetic
efficiency again shalin showed that
objects was part of these plastics and
elitism by studying its interaction with
non
in fact I was by FC and ear I just show
a few example of arm sixth interacting
with rip one here and there are with the
OC one year and there and so I told you
that mostly there's two sides which are
affected in the mutant a CCD and PS BF
and eighth and so and this phenotype too
and so the question was which which side
is responsible for the phenotype and we
had strong presumption that it was the
PS BF defect in editing because we add a
mutant in the lab which is affecting in
the acc d and i show you a picture at
the very beginning of the talk and
there's no phenotype associated with
these mutants so in order to demonstrate
that the PhDs deflecting editing was
responsible for the for this phenotype
small growth and photosynthetic
deficiency what he indeed was a pretty
cool experiment she took PS BF and with
the g genomically encoded and she
transformed a plant mutant and so you
can see here it's translated and here in
green is the transit peptide that allows
the protein to goes in a chloroplast and
again this red meaning that the this
protein is already edited and then by
doing that she was able to at least
partially complements the defect the
morphological defect where you can see
you have to trust me but the even though
these transgenic plants are not at the
level of the white side they are much
better and much bigger than the than the
mutant and also the photosynthetic
efficiency even though is not at the
level of the wild-type is much better
than Newton's and so in other words that
demonstrating that the defect
of picea PS BF editing is a one
responsible for the the morphology
morphological defect we observe in
English mutants so in summary I hope
that today I convince you that the plant
it is ozone is complex and contain at
least for protein families for the
plastid so the PPR which are the
recognition sorry the PPR the ribs which
are also called moss the arms and the
O's but only three protein families have
been identified of sofa in the
mitochondrial editor zone and they are
the same the PPR the more ribs and the
arms also the plant elitism is really
diverse in its composition not only in
ppl at the content because the PPR
differ for every side you got the ugly
the recognition factor but also in
regards to these other components there
are other rib and for instance so today
I told you about 20 m 1 and m 6 which
are plastic aging factor and the side
another control of difference the two
sides mostly affected by the m6 mutants
are not affected by the on one mutant so
in other words they are editors am
classically to them that content on one
and order that contain object depending
on which side the gonna modify and m6 is
a unique usual on protein because it
really recognized a very small number of
targets only really two mostly to when
other or all the other on the plastid or
or mitochondrial really recognize and
affect many many
sides this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu